zunächst interessiert unsere zuschauer
natürlich wie sahra wagenknecht geht der
artikel heute bei bild.de wurde
millionenfach abgerufen die menschen
haben sich damit beschäftigt wie geht es
sarah wagenknecht die ja immer wieder
gesagt hat dass sie sich nicht hat
impfen lassen und jetzt mit krone
angesteckt hat frau wagenknecht sie sind
uns telefonisch zugeschaltet wie geht
sie ja also ich wollte ja sagen ich habe
natürlich schon eine gewisse sorge
gehabt irgendwann ein positives ergebnis
zu bekommen das war jetzt auf absehbar
oder gar nicht zu überraschen bisher
geht mit dem reboot ich merke gar nicht
ich hoffe einfach macht es ändert sich
nicht mehr in den nächsten tagen oder
werden dann zumindest ein milder
verlaufen es gibt ja viele zuschauer
auch hierbei führte nach acht die immer
über impfpflicht diskutieren über das
impfen und viele fragen sich soll ich
mich doch noch impfen lassen oder soll
es bleiben lassen wenn sie jetzt corona
bekommen haben denken sie sie hätten sie
doch besser machen sollen oder denken
sie jetzt
sind passiert also ich finde dich
entscheiden also bei mir gab es einfach
auch bestimmte gesundheitliche gründe
warum ich mich nicht entziehen wollte
weil ich sorge hatte dass sich da
bestimmt lichtinger verstärken könnten
und letztlich ja es muss halt jeder sein
risiko abwägen also älter jemand ist
oder wenn er bestimmte erkrankung hat
diabetes zb oder sehr starkes
übergewicht da weiß man da ist das
risiko eben sehr hoch da ist es
sicherlich auch empfehlenswert sich
impfen zu lassen junge leute mögen das
anders sehen ich finde einfach es ist
das recht von jedem dass selbst zu
entscheiden
wenn sie jetzt darüber nachdenken dass
die impfpflicht eben viel diskutiert
worden ist und die frage für sie zu
hause wie verhalten sie sich jetzt in
den nächsten tagen und haben sie sorge
dass sie möglicherweise verwandte
angehörige angesteckt haben können
ich habe zum glück die letzten tage
eigentlich für zurückgezogen verbracht
also ich war zu hause und
da ist man auf gute kämpfer der einzige
der da im risiko ist ansonsten ja man
hat er sich angestellt nicht dass wir
wissen also hat es keinen test bis jetzt
gemacht weil das hier inzwischen auch
nicht mehr so ist dass man das immer
muss aber oder auch überhaupt sollte
aber es geht ihm gut und insoweit hoffe
ich mal dass ich da ihn auch nicht
angesteckt habe und ich werde natürlich
die nächsten tage zu hause bleiben ist
ja völlig klar und auch niemanden mehr
treffen weil ich möchte ja auch
niemanden gefährden also das ist ja
völlig verständlich worauf wir freuen
uns dass es ihnen gut geht aber wir
wollen hier bei 48 natürlich auch
diskutieren und sie haben ein thema
mitgebracht was sie am heutigen tag
besonders bewegt hat
ja wir haben ja heute im bundestag die
erste impfpflicht debatte orientierungs
debatte erlebt ich habe die konkurse aus
verfolgt und ich muss sagen ich finde
die argumente der befürworter wirklich
nach wie vor überhaupt nicht überzeugend
also selbstbestimmte argumente die man
im herbst vielleicht noch bringen konnte
nimmt inzwischen nicht mehr wirklich
relevant weil die omikron welle lässt
sich ja durch die impfung oder
impfpflicht ohnehin nicht verhindern die
ihr wollt jetzt durch sehr viele
menschen werden sich infizieren und
jetzt ist das hauptargument der
impfpflicht befürworter das würde mich
brauchen damit wir im herbst nicht schon
wieder in eine neue infektionsfälle
hineinkommen aber ich muss sagen da sind
mir zu viele wenn und zu viele nicht so
viel nicht wissen ist mir das spiel also
erstens viele biologen erwarten jetzt
dass tatsächlich nach oregon wir in eine
sogenannte ensi mini kommen also dass
das virus eben durch die abschwächung
die wir mit ronja sehen die milden
verläufe dass es dadurch eben die
bevölkerung so stark inspiziert dass die
viele menschen auch immun sind und dafür
dann keine pandemie mehr haben und auch
womöglich die nicht mehr diese belastung
genutzt als system das weiß natürlich
mann der laut aber auch
profitiert ja schon wieder irgendwelche
grusel mutanten die im herbst kommen die
dann wieder viel viel gefährlicher sind
natürlich könnte das theoretisch auch
sein ich glaube das kann niemand
ausschließen aber selbst dann bilden wir
nicht auf die jetzigen impfstoffe gegen
diese mutanten überhaupt wirken wir
sehen ja schon bei auch mikron wirken
sie sehr viel weniger wir wissen auch
nicht ob ein impfschutz der brüder
erworben wird im herbst noch wirklich
voll da ist das war jetzt letzten jahr
das problem die die früher der
frühzeitig gefunden hatten im herbst
einen nachlassenden in schuss sind gab
es dann ein poster und all das sind ja
doch dinge die er im wagen liegen und
unter solchen voraussetzungen jetzt
menschen zu verpflichten sich zu impfen
ich finde das kann man einfach nicht
rechtfertigen das ist ja ein sehr sehr
gravierender eingriff in die körperliche
unversehrtheit und dafür muss es
wirklich zwingende gründe geben bei dem
brocken damals da hatte man einen
impfstoff mit dem man das virus
ausbreiten konnte bei der nase und
impfung hat man einen impfstoff wo jeder
dicker sein kann er kann niemanden mehr
anstecken er kann sich auch nie wieder
infizieren da gab es und gibt es im
schlichten aber das sind völlig andere
voraussetzungen als bei corona und ich
würde mir vielmehr wünschen wenn man
sich auf den herbst vorbereiten will und
das sollte man tun dass endlich
ernsthaft etwas gegen den pflegenotstand
unternommen wird und dagegen dass in den
krankenhäusern eben immer wieder
überlastungen sind weil das kennen wir
doch schon vor krone auf fortuna gab
immer in großen grippewellen die
situation dass die intensivstation voll
waren des patienten verlegt werden
mussten das operation verschoben werden
mussten und das zeigt uns doch wir
müssen dringend mehr ressourcen in das
gesundheitssystem investieren bessere
gehälter zahlen mehr pflegekräfte aber
eher lauterbach macht das gegenteil mit
der einrichtung bezogenen impfpflicht
wird sich der pflegenotstand zu schärfen
und dann wieder zu sagen ja jetzt haben
wir wieder eine noch größere belastung
und wir haben müssen wieder grundrechte
einschränken ich finde aus dieser
spirale müssen wir raus kommen
bloß wenn sie da diese argumente von
vorwagen nicht werden wie können sie da
sagen wir brauchen diese ihn vielleicht
trotzdem also zunächst möchte ich erst
mal gute besserung wünschen und hoffe
dass es ihr bald wieder gut geht und ich
kann die argumente durchaus
nachvollziehen das will ich als jemand
der zu einer impfpflicht tendiert auch
ausdrücklich sagen das ist keine
einfache debatte natürlich ist das auch
ein schwerer eingriff und einen eingriff
in die freiheit eines individuums aber
umgekehrt ist es doch so dass wir im
moment seit einigen wochen eine art
locker und leid haben und als
gesellschaft mit massiven grund und
freizeit schenkungen leben müssen dass
wir in vielen bundesländern
über die kapazitäten auf den
intensivstationen schon hinaus waren
patienten ausgeflogen werden mussten und
das ist konkurrieren drei strecken die
lärm und das gesundheitssystem schon
auch wirklich am rande der
kapazitätsgrenzen stabsstelle etwas nur
noch in sachsen in bayern mussten ja
patienten auch in andere bundesländer
ausgeflogen werden wollen das auch schon
in anderen krankheitsfällen passiert ja
aber das kroner dann natürlich für eine
besonders schwerwiegende situation in
den krankenhäusern sorgt das ist glaube
ich offenkundig und wird auch niemand
bestreiten und jetzt ist ja die frage
wenn wir auf den nächsten herbst und
winter schauen wollen wir das gleiche
noch mal durchspielen und ich möchte
unbedingt verhindern dass es zu weiteren
krawallen kommt und dass wir weitere
lockdown erleben und ich glaube in der
abwägung ist dann eine impfpflicht da
kann man jetzt diskutieren ob ab 50 oder
ab 18 doch der bessere weg weil ich
befürchte dass wir ansonsten in jedem
winter und herbst das gleiche erleben
wie in den letzten zwei jahren verfiel
interessante sachen gesagt damit das
interessanteste wort ist sie tendieren
zu einer impfpflicht können sie denn
noch umstimmen heute abend also ich bin
natürlich immer guten argumenten
aufgeschlossen aber ich bin schon
überzeugt dass eine impfpflicht hilft es
gibt ein argument das hat er auch frau
wagenknecht eben vorgetragen würden
tatsächlich jetzt wir in die endemische
lage kommen und wir das ist ja die
hoffnung zumindest von einigen wir
wissen dass im moment noch nicht corona
so eine art schnupfen wird und wir damit
sehr gut umgehen können dann glaube ich
gibt es tatsächlich keine gründe mehr
für eine impfpflicht weil wir dann damit
gut umgehen können dann kann den beweis
liefern nämlich ganz persönlich ich habe
bereits zum zweiten mal corona bekommen
weil meine reise in kiew und war
dreifach geimpft die wirkung dessen war
das ist wirklich nur schnupfen war
tatsächlich allerdings frage ich mich
wenn wir politiker auch aus ihrer partei
erzählt haben in den vergangenen monaten
und jahren
das ist doch so sei dass man damit
corona dann nicht mehr bekommt und ich
es jetzt schon zum zweiten mal bekommen
habe dann frage ich mich wussten die
politiker eigentlich worüber sie reden
und waren diese impfstoffe wirklich so
gut und ich verstehe diese erklärung die
da jetzt kommen nämlich ja
möglicherweise gibt es dann ja wieder
eine grusel mutation so hat frau
wagenknecht das finde ich sehr treffend
bezeichnet und dann braucht man ja
vielleicht ein impfstoff der irgendwie
vielleicht wirkt aber keiner weiß irgend
was genau ist wie können sie denn da die
mir das nicht tatsächlich dann die
menschen verpflichten so an impfstoff ja
dann
zu nehmen das ist tatsächlich ja das
große problem bei der korona krise
insgesamt dass wir immer wieder neue
entwicklung haben die keiner vorausahnen
konnte und dass wir eventuell auch
entwicklung bekommen werden in den
nächsten monaten die wir heute in dieser
runde und in ganz deutschland gar nicht
voraus an können so deswegen kann es
immer sein dass man das auch hier und da
anpassen muss auch die fdp zum beispiel
hat der ihre position zur impfpflicht
sehr stark verändert aber ich kann das
ganze auch umdrehen wenn wir jetzt sehen
wir haben weitere mutationen die bei
einer geringen impfquote dazu führen
dass die intensivstation schnell
überlastet sind dann werde ich doch im
nächsten herbst und winter wieder über
wochen grund und freizeit schränken
haben und die pflegekräfte die kommen
irgendwann an ihr limit und wenn frau
wagenknecht sagt sie möchte die
pflegekräfte entlasten da muss sie mal
mit vielen pflegekräften sprechen denn
die sagen wenn wir noch mal so was
erleben dann hören wir bald auf und
gehen woanders nicht mehr wie siehst du
das die impfpflicht es wissen die
zuschauer verständlich dass du klar
dagegen ist dann wenn man jetzt die
argumente hören also muss ich sagen dass
ich frau wagenknecht sehr dankbar wenn
das sie sich als politikern auch
öffentlich immer so dagegen stellt und
ich muss ja auch für rückgrat
gratulieren ich fand es großartig dass
sie das auch weiterhin wie sie von ihrer
eigenen medizinischen entscheidung
überzeugt weil durchgezogen hat auch im
öffentlichen druck weil das ist es das
impfen ist eine medizinisch persönliche
entscheidung die jeder für sich alleine
trifft ich finde es furchtbar dass es
heutzutage so ist jeder sagt seinen
impfstatus früher hat man nicht jedem er
erstmal seinen impfbuch gezeigt wenn man
sich getroffen hat beispielsweise zum
kaffee heute ist dass so was nicht ganz
doll stört an dieser impfpflicht und
weswegen ich es furchtbar finde auch
wenn ich natürlich respektiere wie du
darüber denkt finde ich es furchtbar
wenn ich daran denke dass menschen dazu
gezwungen werden dann ist es kein zwang
aber sie werden ja immer mehr dazu
gebracht geflüchtete verpflichtet es ist
eine impfpflicht keinen impfzwang amazon
ist aber ich sage ganz gleich wie gegen
lebenslicht wir dürfen menschen doch
keinen medizinischen eingriff auf
doktoren und ich habe eine frage noch
die die mir auch sehr wichtig ist es
gibt ja auch ins nebenwirkungen und
darüber reden wir viel zu wenig im
deutschen fernsehen wir ihnen generell
viel zu wenig darüber es gibt aber
impfnebenwirkungen in meinem
bekanntenkreis oder sogar familiären
kreis gibt es auch einen fall wo im
nebenwirkungen aufgetreten sind es sind
natürlich einzelfälle aber es gibt es
das heißt ihr die frage ist wirklich wie
kannst du jemanden verpflichten sich
impfen zu lassen und ihnen dazu ja
eigentlich dann zwingend immer mehr
hintreiben was ist wenn dieser mensch
plötzlich impfschäden hat es ist immer
die möglichkeiten beim medizin statt
also das ist ja völlig klar dass das
wirklich eine schwierige entscheidung
ist und dass es auch solche fälle leider
gibt aber es ist gerade in der politik
bei so schwierigen fragen immer eine
abwägung und ich kann das auch umdrehen
und sagen ist wurden im winter dieses
jahres und ende letzten jahres
operationen verschoben von menschen die
krebs hatten oder haben es wurden hätten
ja weil die kapazitäten einfach nicht da
waren es wollen alle kapazitäten
teilweise in den krankenhäusern
zusammengezogen um die korona patienten
zu versorgen oder auf den
intensivstationen mitzuhelfen so und
dann gibt es natürlich massive grund und
frites einschränkung auch für
gewerbetreibende die in den schulen hat
man das gemerkt also alle wissen das ja
in dem fußballstadion der bild hat ja
häufig auch darüber berichtet und jetzt
ist dort die frage wollen wir das alles
wieder riskieren dass wir sagen im
nächsten herbst und winter haben wir
eventuell wieder drei monate so eine
situation und in den krankenhäusern
es wird den krebskranken patienten
gesagt tut mir leid operation muss
verschoben werden das finde ich kann man
nicht akzeptieren
politiker sind die in aller regel
schlaue leute und sie haben sicherlich
auch ihr
früheren parteichef findet immer gut zu
wort die gesagt hat man muss dinge ja
vom ende her denken das war eine ihrer
großen wenn wir jetzt eine impfpflicht
einführen und die bringt aber nichts
weil leute werden weiter krank an krone
erkranken um ikon oder c gründen oder
grusel mutationen und wir haben
sozusagen trotz einer impfpflicht trotz
des umstands dass ultima ratio gezogen
hat weiter dieses große das land
beeinträchtigende die menschlichen das
menschliche zusammenleben
beeinträchtigende phänomen plus es gibt
im folgen die wir jetzt noch gar nicht
absehen können was erzählen sie dann den
na ja es mag ich habe damals ich war
damals halt mit gestimmt und jetzt
wieder anders und haben wir wieder was
dazugelernt zu den erfolgen kann man ja
eins sei es gab ja sehr umfangreiche
klinische studien und man hat ja nicht
anderen impfstoff auf den markt gegeben
und das sind jetzt alles
versuchskaninchen
deswegen bin ich da sehr zuversichtlich
dass sich irgendwelche im stehen in
wirklich überschaubarem maße sehr stark
in grenzen halten und wie gesagt ist
eine abwägung umgekehrt gibt es sehr
viele die erkrankten die dann auch
sterben und die intensivstation werden
überlastet aber natürlich hilft das nur
am ende wenn es auch sinnvoll ist und
wenn es dazu beiträgt dass zum beispiel
intensivstation nicht überlastet werden
an der loire und häufig das gefühl
bieten obwohl oder vorher hinter ihrer
partei nicht sinnvoll war